[Applause]
i appreciate that very much
you uh
are in a crazy good mood
i think i know why it's probably because
nascar is here
what it's new to in l.a this weekend we
have nascar there's something we've
never seen before traffic moving
no i get it
oh
oh and we have the super bowl
that's pretty exciting and we're and la
is
in the super bowl the team did you see
the big game la and san francisco and
all the politicians from the state were
there and
not wearing masks they got a picture of
them well they said they just took the
mask off for the picture uh mayor
garcetti said he'd literally said this
he said i held my breath the whole time
wow he said that
at least when bill clinton said he
didn't inhale he was getting high you
know
held his breath come on
but
our president had a better week uh
more job creation in his first year than
ever
that's not a bad thing
and just
even with omicron in january we added
500 000 new jobs now a lot of those jobs
were uh fox news guests talking about
how bad the economy is
but still their jobs
oh did you see it
now uh president biden
i love this every year the prayer
breakfast
how many go
no
uh it's fantastic the national prayer
breakfast and he took a moment out to
single mitch mcconnell out and said
mitch thank you for being a great friend
and
that
that reporter that joe insulted last
week he stood up and said wait and i'm
the stupid son of a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's perspective always my theme here
the republican national committee
has now censured liz cheney and adam
kissinger the two republicans who are
honest about what happened with the
election this is the difference i mean i
call out the left as you know i do and
they are way off track but the
republicans are a party that is just
about having a creepy fealty to one man
they're not really republicans anymore
they're like bts fans
and if you
tweet out k-pop socks they go mental
[Applause]
now every i mean at this whole
everybody is just canceling everybody
else
nobody talks
they just want to kill their i mean
spotify have you seen this thing that's
going on with spotify because the
musicians don't like joe rogan so crosby
was crosby stills nash and young uh are
have it's true
have all pulled themselves off spotify
you know it's getting to the point where
they're no fun anymore
oh two people remember that song i think
that i think that says a lot
but yeah
so
[Applause]
and that's not why it's a big threat
but it's crosby stills nash young johnny
mitchell the head of spotify the ceo
said he feels terrible about this but
not as bad as it was 1972
you